are you excited for injustice to but
worried about the prospect of its
microtransactions well developer
NetherRealm has revealed exactly what
they are and I'm gonna run you through
them right now
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
stay up-to-date on all of the injustice
2 coverage and character reveals
according to nether realm and justice to
source crystals are not pay2win items
they're only used to purchase cosmetic
adjustments premier character skins and
various costume shaders on top of that
source crystals can also be used to make
one piece of gear look like another or
level up your characters after one of
them reaches level 20 nether realm says
that none of these options offer a
competitive edge during gameplay so you
don't have to worry about the riches
player having an unfair advantage in
justice 2 launches for ps4 and Xbox one
on may 16th there have been a bunch of
character reveals over the past couple
months including Black Canary cheetah
and Swamp Thing and we're expecting
another announcement on March 23rd we'll
report back when the new character has
been revealed but if you want more
superhero action right now check out our
GameSpot Universe channel where we cover
all of your favorite movies TV shows and
comic books
[Music]